we have taken up the question today of
what happens when coaches test positive
for covet especially during the season
so our draft team's best situated if the
head coach misses time during the
regular season with covet 19. trivia
question that i've just kind of pulled
out of the air chris let's see if you
know the answer to this who's the last
nfl head coach who suffered a broken leg
in a sideline collision oh gosh wait
damn
i i mean i i i know i know this i mean
i'm gonna choke and i mean i you know of
course
man
oh i want to say it was like here in new
york too or something but i i can't
remember who was it mike tell me sean
payton oh
man and where did he do that what
was it down in town in tampa it was in
tampa yeah jeez yeah you better watch
out when you're on the sideline
he didn't miss any games be coached from
the booth i think uh there have been
coaches who have missed games and we may
see coaches miss games this year uh
regardless of whether or not they're
symptomatic that's the thing if you're
positive with the virus you're not going
to be there until the virus clears your
symptoms as your system even if you have
no symptoms all right first pick for me
and there are a lot of teams that i
think would would be not necessarily
okay but they'd be able to weather the
storm right i'm gonna start with the
tampa bay buccaneers because for all
practical purposes the head coach is in
uniform this year he's tom brady and and
bruce arians who has delegated plenty of
authority and responsibility to his
coordinators byron left which would run
the offense todd bowles runs the defense
tom brady runs the team
the tampa bay buccaneers would be fine
if bruce arians is unavailable for a
couple of weeks with covid night so
you're just saying they're going to let
brady run the game situations like hey
hey he's going to yell over being
sarcastic he's going to yell over the
left witch and balls and be like hey
we're going for it here but yeah mom
it's 40. 24. i don't care
no i know what you mean i know i'm just
having fun with you um okay that's i
mean i understand that and it certainly
does help to have a veteran quarterback
like a brady to sued that over but i'm
just i'm kind of shocked by that first
pick i think there's a lot better
options out there i mean go ahead and
make your parting with your squad you're
gonna just not think of your squad
what's the way you too good for your
team
how dare you the minnesota vikings you
know i don't know anybody else knowing a
a super bowl
you know winning head coach who's an
assistant on any of these teams i can't
think of one off the top of my head so
i'm going with them
i'll take the six-time super bowl
winning quarterback over the one-time
super bowl winning offensive court okay
yeah apparently yes okay so you're bar
picking tom brady to coach the team so
that's your pick and i don't like it
then it's stupid all right now minnesota
yes i'd feel okay if zimmer was gone and
now you got gary kubiak running the show
i mean he's been around mike shanahan of
course he's played he coached the texans
won a super bowl with the denver broncos
knows how to do it a lot of different
ways that to me was the the obvious
picker for me it was the obvious pick i
i well it's on my list but i just
wouldn't call it the obvious pick
because i think that that that bruce
arians has already set it up
where
he's just kind of an overseer anyway and
i don't mean to take anything away from
bruce arians here but he puts so much
faith in his guys and he's got a
quarterback unlike any quarterback he's
ever had except for maybe peyton manning
but that was a long time ago but you
have an accomplished guy who's going to
come in and provide the accountability
the leadership the example that's set
the ability to to speak to the young
players and get them to do what needs to
be done i just i think bruce aryan
arguably has the easiest job of any head
coach this year making him the easiest
coach to replace if there is a covert 19
situation and aaron's one of the coaches
we hope doesn't end up testing positive
because he's got the comorbidities and
he's close to 70 years old so uh you
know for a lot of these guys are going
to be completely asymptomatic but uh i i
don't want to see the dice get rolled
with uh someone like bruce arians all
right next one for me
well
this one is
less about the credentials of the
offensive coordinator and more about the
inexperience of the head coach if joe
judge is unavailable for the new york
giants jason garrett takes over now you
know who knows that the results are
going to be all that great but uh
but
i think you're right it's it's an
unproven commodity in joe judge and
jason garrett just steps right in the
guy's been a head coach for the last
decade he just steps right in and takes
the team over until joe judge comes back
it'll be a seamless transition that no
that that's a pic that made sense i like
that one better okay but yeah i hear
what you're saying i mean you're right i
mean first off jason garrett yeah we're
talking about if your head coach you
know gets sick who's who's who's gonna
be the team that's best set up to to be
able to handle it jason garrett first
off yeah been a head coach been to the
playoffs a bunch of times and like
nobody
nobody i mean he doesn't panic he's so
calm and i think you know that would be
the type of guy you'd want to take over
like oh man our head coach is going on
what's going to happen you know he would
he would soothe people over in that
organization very very quickly um
all right well i'm going to kansas city
next i am because you know i look at
kansas city and go damn they got three
head coaches on their on their staff
behind andy reid in my opinion you know
first off hey you're right the team's
good already we know that they got a
great quarterback to your tampa thing so
you got patrick mahomes that gives you a
great
so you like my pick now well i like want
quarterbacks that are under 30. but
either way
okay so but then you add into
eric b enemy steve spagnolo who has been
a head coach in the nfl and of course a
super bowl winning defensive coordinator
and then dave taub who's been in the
conversation for being a head coach for
a long long time as one of the better
special teams coaches in the in the
sport so i just look at that and go oh
you got a good team there you got you
know three guys who certainly can handle
their workload and i don't know who gets
appointed to be the head guy or the the
guy that makes the big decisions but i
think it's three guys who understand the
game and where the organization's going
and they know how to handle their
business and that seems to be a pretty
good situation to me
yeah and i think you've touched on
something that's important here quality
of player yeah makes it easier to go
forward without the coach the better the
team
the the more the team can self-coach
itself as you would say sure that's why
that's why
i'm gonna go to baltimore
when you consider the quality of the
roster yeah best team in the nfl last
year in the record of season 14 and two
you've got greg roman who can run the
offense you've got don martindale who
can run the defense if john harbaugh
tests positive and isn't available the
ravens will k and this you know and this
is where it gets awkward because john
harpal is one of the best coaches in the
nfl he was coach of the year last year
but if he's not available this ship is
going to run itself chris yeah no i mean
i i don't doubt that you know the value
of a guy like john harbaugh
is you know it's his during the week
preparation oh i like this matchup oh i
don't like that matchup i don't think we
should do that he's got a great feel on
the sidelines for when to go for it when
to punt you know feeling the vibe
jackson does
mark jackson does but either way i give
him a lot of credit he listens to the
player there and that's instance and
goes you know what i i feel him there
he's right i could see that the you know
his energy is in the right place
whatever he's got a great feel for the
game that way and that is hard to
replace but you're you know also your
that team is damn good and you got you
know wink martindale and greg roman
there too who we know can coach some
football too and and certainly they're
not going to like crash and burn um
man this is where there's there's so a
lot of a lot of good ones and this is
where i'm not sure which all right i
think i'm just going to go i'm going to
go out to denver broncos i am i'm going
to go there
because
first off you got a guy you know vic
fangio long time overdue should have
been a head coach but great defense of
mine you got pat shurmur there as an
offensive coordinator who's been a head
coach and then to add on to that you got
mike munchek as the offensive line coach
who's also been a head coach so i just
think when i look at those three things
again obviously i've gone with the
support system and the coaching staff
more than anything here uh but when you
have two former ex-head coaches and you
know a mike munchek who's been around
for as long as he's been
and understands what it takes to to
build game-winning game plans and
everything like that i just think
they're in a good spot to where they'll
figure it out and have the right
leadership and the egos aren't too big
to where i think like shermer or munchak
will be like no i'm coaching the team
you coach the team i'm coaching the team
so that's one that jumps out
i also had the falcons on the list
because you've got former head coach and
dirk cutter yeah as offensive
coordinator former head coach raheem
morris and defensive coordinator veteran
quarterback in matt ryan talent on the
roster and i don't see a big drop off if
dan quinn isn't available who else did
you have that didn't make the case yeah
i had the i had the chargers because of
gus bradley and
you know him being the ex jags coach
defensive coordinator there that made
sense to me you know the jaguars with
doug marone yeah well hey jay gruden's
there he's only a year out of being a
head coach too so that's not bad and
he's worked with some of those guys on
that staff before as well so you know
that was one that jumped out and then at
the bills sean mcdermott leslie frazier
being up there brian dabal who's a guy
who's gonna be in the head coach
conversation i expect after this year
those are the ones that jumped out to me
mike
i was intrigued by the patriots but i
didn't know what to do and i wasn't
going to make them the pick because even
though josh mcdaniels presumably would
take over
i i still i you got to have belichick on
the sideline for the patriots to be the
patriots right
you got to uh yes i mean i think
belichick i mean mcdaniels and they were
on my list too where he's like he's he's
as close as he's going to get into that
organization as far as being able to
approach it exactly like a belichick
definitely uh i don't know also the
weird thing too is his son's there on
the staff and everything like that i
just thought that dynamic was a little
odd but uh i i think josh mcdaniels will
certainly handle it there's no doubt
he's just gonna have to listen to bill
and zoom meetings all week and take his
take the lead from there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports